[Musik]
sebastian nimmt sich den praktischen
coffee to go aus dem kühlregal vor
ich habe es das schwarze gold lege packt
aus und mixed supersüßen latte macchiato
berlin industrie
guten morgen
wie verbringen sie ihren morgen ich
brauch erst mal kaffee so einen schönen
latte macchiato
wasser was schönes
lecker aber
auch ganz schön aufwendig oder milch
aufschäumen den espresso kocher offen
herstellen das geht auch viel viel
schneller kennen sie die produkte hier
latte macchiato eis
gekühlt
ob latte macchiato oder café latte lege
packt aus milch milcherzeugnisse heißen
sie offiziell
oktober wie creme ich so ein bisschen
wie so ein cacau damals aus der schule
[Musik]
hunt gerösteter kaffee darin kommen die
mache ich doch mal auf dass wir hier ein
qualitätsversprechen
so süß
ein schöner alge drinnen zum binden
ne-yo hier
aber das ist längst nicht alles
kollegen was damit los kaffeezubereitung
wasser kaffee extrakt 20 prozent zucker
der extrakt natürlich ist kaffeearoma
soll regulatoren
ohne die blitze rede von speise
fettsäuren
[Musik]
sebastian lee gezeigt wie aus alldem
jetzt ein fertig latte macchiato wird
statt frisch aufgebrühten kaffee setzen
viele hersteller café extrakt 1 oder
anders instantkaffee
[Musik]
legen wir los
jetzt machen wir erstmal unser
kaffeepulver
das setzt die aromen aus den gerösteten
kaffeebohnen frei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er rät wirklich gut
[Musik]
für den instant kaffee müssen die
löslichen stoffe aus dem kaffeepulver
extrahiert werden
[Musik]
der kampf wird
der kaffee ist fertig und soeben habe
ich von ein paar kaffeebohnen dessen
aromatik extrahiert
ich glaube aber kaffee aufgebrüht
[Gelächter]
aber wir müssen ja jetzt ins denn daraus
machen normalerweise funktioniert das
per sprühtrocknung in der industrie wird
bei diesem verfahren flüssiges café
konzentrat durch feine düsen in einen
trocknungs turm gepumpt durch den strömt
heiße luft die die kleinen café
tröpfchen während des fallens trocknet
so entstehen winzige feste café partikel
die sich am boden des turms sammeln so
sebastian muss sich allerdings anders
behelfen
für den sprühtrocknung stunde haben wir
keine baugenehmigung bekommen deswegen
machen wir unsere instant kaffee genauso
hierzu unsere extraktion von
kaffeebohnen
wird hier auf gekippt
hier
mein trocken apparat
flüssigkeit rein
ventilator 40 grad nicht so heiß nicht
ganz zu machen leichten spalten lassen
darauf weil das wasser soll weg bis das
gesamte wasser verdampft ist dauert es
eigentlich mehrere tage aber sebastian
hat da schon mal was vorbereitet
[Musik]
ich hab es das schwarze gold
jetzt noch in der kaffeemühle
zerkleinern hersteller von fertigem
latte macchiato sparen mit instantkaffee
einen ganzen produktionsschritt der muss
nicht mehr gebrüllt werden er wird nur
mit wasser vermischt
ein klassischer latte macchiato besteht
zu gut 30 prozent aus kaffee in den
bechern aus dem supermarkt stecken nur
zwischen 15 und 23 prozent kaffee
hauptzutat dieser produkte die milch die
macht drei viertel des getränks aus
jetzt fehlt nur noch wenige bindungen
weil wir sollen also denken das ist so
aus oder aufgeschäumt nehme ich diese
richtig schön cremig sahnig sich angaben
langsam herunter schmid
bindemittel
boa kamel ein kalt binder das heißt denn
kalte flüssigkeiten bindet er schon und
machten die cremige konsistenz
cara gen weiterer binder
so
karall gehen wird aus einer eigene
gewonnen
und war aus verschiedenen roth eigen
wenn diese algen mit einer lauge
behandelt werden entsteht cara
georg kern mail wird aus der bohne
gewonnen eine pflanze die vor allem in
indien und pakistan wächst
doch damit nicht genug
[Musik]
dann haben wir mono die ganze riege von
speise fettsäuren
die sorgen dafür dass das produkt eine
konstante stabilität hat das wasser und
fett sich miteinander liebhaben und bloß
nicht trennen jetzt brauchen noch ein
bisschen aroma denn wo an echtem café
gespart wird hilft kaffee aroma und
damit das produkt mehrere wochen im
kühlregal stehen kann noch ein bisschen
was für die haltbarkeit kalium karbonat
säure regulator der sorgt dafür dass
gewisse spitzen in aromatik ab gedeckelt
werden und es sind man gleich und
harmonisch schmeckt ich probier mal
das sieht aus wie spülwasser
[Musik]
für mich wäre es okay aber
die produkte die wir gerade probiert
haben hatten deutlich mehr zucker pro
100 milliliter enthalten die fertig
cafés zwischen 5,7 und 8,8 gramm zucker
pro becher sind das rund fünf bis acht
stücke würfelzucker die
weltgesundheitsorganisation empfiehlt
maximal 50 gramm zucker pro tag mit nur
einem becher starbucks kaffee sind schon
37 prozent der tageshöchst menge
erreicht
[Musik]
11 wo ist süß
so viel zucker im café olé gemacht das
produkt länger haltbar aber das ist
nicht der einzige grund für eine so hohe
zuckermenge
[Musik]
in diesen kaffee getränken sorgt der
zucker natürlich auch dafür dass der
kaffee gar nicht mehr so bitter schmeckt
und das vielleicht auch menschen die
sonst keinen kaffee trinken würden gerne
zu diesen produkten greifen wir wollen
wissen wie gut der über süß der
industrie kaffee wirklich ankommt und
haben zu einer verkostung eingeladen im
weiß markierten glas servieren wir
kalten ungesüßten café latte aus einer
starbucks filiale
das schwarz markierte glas ist mit dem
gezuckerten produkt aus dem kühlregal
gefüllt
bitte probieren einfach mal sagen wie
schmeckt welcher kaffee kann mehr
überzeugen alle testerinnen und tester
probieren erst den ungesüßten kaffee und
anschließend das fertige
industrieprodukt
also es hat schon mehr nach kaffee
schmeckt ich trinke persönlich keinen
kaffee okay deswegen hat der schwarze
kaffee mehr besser geschmeckt bei der
zusätzlicher schmeckt der ist wirklich
sehr süß
fast ein bisschen mehr schmeckt der
schwarze das süßer und mir schmeckt süß
besser mir schmeckt auf jeden fall der
schwarze auch besser ich hätte den
ersten besser gefunden weil ja gerade
weniger sie es ist mir schmeckt
tatsächlich der weiß das weil ich im
nächsten findet ihr den schwarzen
der fertig kaffee macht tatsächlich das
rennen er schmeckt sogar testerinnen und
tester die sonst keinen kaffee trinken
und das mit einer mischung aus
instantkaffee viel milch einigen
zusatzstoffen aber vor allem die super
und wenn ihr lust habt auf mehr
tricksereien dann klickt ihr und den
abonnieren -button natürlich nicht
vergessen die em findet ihr dort
[Gelächter]